we are the only show that has gotten
ahold of the audio from I can't believe
it
and it's probably illegal for me to do
this but once again I think it is my
sworn duty to share these calls with you
these are real check it out hey what's
the deal with the Gibbs what do you mean
nobody wants to give me a dagger you
should not be accepting gifts from Amal
no I already accepted it my question is
where do I keep it I mean where do you
keep your attackers I never owned any
Tigers seriously though Tigers yeah
sorry I would just die by shoe what a
Milky Way it's as vicar's without
peanuts okay three musketeers it's a
milky way without caramel fern well
they're just attracting ingredients in
calling it a new god of Getti I've I
agree my wrath
it's no big deal bomb oh do I talk to
the secretary can you buy there's no
such person that yes there is it's based
on full disclosure you're on
speakerphone okay who's there with you
that easy they have an idea a little
extra I just looked at a map of our
border with Mexico it's really blog JD
don't worry I just know the wall that
long that's what I've been trained what
if we could put up a force field like
they did in Star Wars that science
fiction you know I really like Episode
one that was my favorite that's Jar Jar
thing is one of the good ones
Saturdays Fidel Castro you can't I can't
I know a guy who does a guy no you can't
because Fidel Castro already died
earlier this week really huh sounds like
you don't guy who knows the guy is a
face sibel Castro sure you did berries
berries an assassin outstanding your wax
[Applause]
you